so now outcome I'm going to give you
some perspective and some mindset so now
a few data points 53 of Americans say
they rarely or never think about far
future
53 never think about it
some of you are saying 20 years I'm not
going to be thinking 20 years ahead I'm
going to think maybe three weeks ahead
but not 20 years ahead I get it it's not
easy to do
21 report image imagining this future
less than once a year can you imagine
that means one out of five person
even sits there thinking about the
future
it's like all I'm going to be thinking
about is right one out of five so if
you're on the other side you already
have an edge over these guys 32 percent
say never even crosses their mind at all
this is why I asked the question for you
about long-term versus short-term
planning everything's about the question
who do you want to be a recent study
revealed that around 33 percent of small
businesses have a formal business plan
how many of you right now if I called on
you and I said I got a hundred thousand
dollars I'm going to give away right now
who has their formal business plan with
them in their hands right now raise your
hand if you have it with you
raise the end if you have it with you
I'll give you a hundred thousand dollars
stand up if you have it with you stand
up if you have it with you
okay here's another question for you how
many of you guys how many guys
for the year you've read it or looked at
it in the last week
be honest straight up you spent a few
thousand dollars to come here so we
don't need in the last week how many
guys looked at your business plan look
around actually look don't look at me
look around
look around do you by the way some when
people used to do that with me in an
audience I still be like man he's making
me feel like [ __ ] right now stop the
point the point is you just found an
edge here because no one's doing that
everyone's just winging it
your entire competition ninety percent
they're all winging it
and most likely you and I are also
winging it but the Market's wide open
today especially today but no one's
planning so now
the greatest danger this is one of the
greatest Business Consultants and
authors of all time go by every one of
the SE you'll never be disappointed
Peter Drucker he said the greatest
Danger
in times of turbulence is not the
turbulence
it is to act with the act with
yesterday's logic you know what this
means I'm going to solve it the same way
I solved it five years ago it's not
going to work today
it's a different problem today yeah I'm
gonna do the same way I did it 10 years
ago it's not going to work today let me
give you some more perspective out like
I said I was going to give it to you Dow
Jones
anyone know where Dow Jones was on
Friday where did Dow Jones end up with
on Friday anyone knows
what did thou end up on Friday
28 something right and just a few months
ago that was at what 36 7 36 9.
so first time exactly
markets dropped from 37 000 to 28.5 on
Friday I think the market dropped five
six hundred points is what a drop okay
now here's the thing people panic
people panic on what's going on with the
market
this is the Dow in 1957.
did you hear what I just said 1957
Dallas at 435
this is now in 1970 838
this is down 1983. this is only 39 years
ago guys how many guys are older than 39
raising if you're older than 39. you've
lived longer than 30 down 39 years ago
was only at 12 58. that was at 29 right
now
it's 22.8 times since 39 years ago
1996 it was 6400.
you're at graduate high school
2009 10 000 428
2022 as of Friday 28 725
so if we go back and look at what the
Market's done from what was the number
from four something to what
from 4 35 all the way up to
28 000. when you look at this how do you
feel when you hear these numbers when
you look at this how do you feel right
now like what are you thinking about
what does it make you think about
that means long term guess what what's
going to happen long term
we're okay long term now watch this
housing market rates how many of you
love
the rates go from 2.8 just a year ago
to what is it now 683 okay 685 wherever
how many guys love the rates increasing
the way they are
this is raked in 1957. five and a
quarter
1970 eight and a half
1983 3.2 how many guys will like a 3.2
anybody would like a 3.2 you know what
it was in 1981
6.
let me say one more time in 1981
interest rates were 15 to 16 percent and
in two years it went down to 3.2
1995 1996 7.8
2009 5.04 today 6.83
what's the most constant thing that we
notice about the race the last since
1950s what do you notice
always changes okay but even though the
rates are changing let me show you the
next part
average price of a home 1957 19 Grand
1970 25 Grand
1983 64 Grand
1996 100 112 000 2009 188 thousand
dollars 2022
388 thousand dollars what do you notice
throughout the entire time
it never was less
it kept going up again the mindset of
what
long-term thinking you're fine
short term you'll Panic long term you
walk around the room like this hey
Johnny how are you good
you're good Patrick everything good
everything's good man I'm excited bro
you are excited very excited very
hey Larry how are you all right
I don't know man my wife and I had a bad
fight last night how are you everything
good future looks bright man super
excited about the future super excited
about hey Jackie everything good
oh did you hear is today the day that
they already announced the rates I don't
know but guess what what future looks so
bright but I'm so excited about the
future
and eventually everyone's going to get
together you know what they're going to
say I really think pass on ecstasy today
I saw him drinking a lot of water
and his wife was rubbing his back
something's going on with this guy he's
rolling I'm telling you past too happy
today but no you're thinking what
long term while everybody else is
thinking what five minutes
[Music]